Bernie Sanders wants to come out of
Super Tuesday with an insurmountable
lead in delegates and he's expected to
get some of them in his home state of
Vermont Nancy Cordes is in Burlington
that's the state's largest city Nancy
good morning to you what is the Sanders
plan for today well he's going to be
casting his own ballot Gale here at this
Community Center in Burlington his team
hoping that a strong night starts here
in Vermont but stretches to larger
states like Texas and California those
two states alone have nearly half the
delegates that are going to be up for
grabs today and polls show Sanders
leading in both of them one big test for
Sanders today how does he do with
african-americans especially in the
seven southern states that are going to
be voting today over the weekend in
South Carolina he got just 17% of the
black vote compared to Joe Biden's 61%
Sanders has done much better with Latino
voters we saw that in Nevada and they
make up a quarter of the primary
electorate in California he's also got a
stronger ground game bigger crowds than
Biden 15,000 people 25,000 people at
rallies in California over the weekend a
big night tonight for Sanders not an
average night but a big night his
campaign believes would put the delegate
count out of reach for someone like Joe
Biden even if more candidates get out of
this race Gail we'll all be watching
Thank You Nancy